Hi, friends.
I'm so excited to talk to you guys
about something that I've been working on for a while now,
and that is a partnership with World Vision.
World Vision is a Christian organization that focuses on poverty
and families all across the world that are in need.
And after discussing some things with Jake
and looking over their website
and looking over everything that they stand for,
we ourselves
have decided that we are going to start giving monthly
to World Vision. World Vision is launching a new subscription plan
where you can donate monthly to them and actually see a difference
that the change that your money is making.
Instead of you subscribing to something and being promised a product,
if it's going to change your life,
you will actually be making a difference
for people all around the world.
I'm really excited about this organization
because this is one way that you can really help those in need.
You can find all the details in the caption or at worldvision dot org.